in early April Elon surprised the world
when he announced that he had acquired a
9.2 percent stake in Twitter at first he
played a cola and did not make it clear
whether he wanted to buy the company or
not many speculated that Elon was just
trying to join the Twitter board so that
he could influence decisions at the
company without taking over the entire
company the fact that Twitter kept his
take at 15 just made it even less likely
that Elon would attempt to take over but
despite all that it didn't take long for
Elon to make a buyout offer for 41.39
billion dollars and the Twitter board
would eventually accept a bid for 44
billion dollars Elana instantly went
ahead and sold off some Tesla stock and
secured billions of dollars worth of
loans to pay for Twitter all of this
unfolded it within a month so it seemed
like both Verona and Twitter wanted to
get this deal done ASAP but at this
point it's been nearly two months since
Elon secured funding for the Twitter
deal and we've seen virtually no
progress not to mention it Twitter stock
hasn't been doing that grid either which
is not the best of signs if elon's deal
does end up taking place he'd be buying
each year of Twitter for 54.20 so buying
Twitter shares under this price is
basically just free profit as long as
the deal goes through but right now
Twitter stands at just 39.41 meaning
that you'd profit 37 if the deal goes
through at the original price given that
the stock has sold off so much though it
doesn't look like the market is super
confident that the deal will end up
taking place at least not at the
original price so what happened to Elon
tour deal
foreign
starting off with the most noted concern
Elon is worried about how many fake
accounts are on Twitter in terms of fake
accounts we have two main categories
which are inactive accounts and spam
Bots inactive accounts are
self-explanatory these are accounts that
were created years ago and the user
hasn't stopped using Twitter or they
have switched to another account but
this is not what Elon is really talking
about his primary concern with fake
accounts is bambots as YouTube people
are extremely familiar with these
there's probably some crypto expert in
the comment section down below named
Mary Jane who 40 people are willing to
vouch for such spammers generally
account for an extremely small portion
of social media however given that each
spammer operates 30 to 50 accounts they
actually make up a decent amount of the
total accounts Twitter says that fake
accounts make up less than five percent
of their daily active users but being an
avid Twitter user himself Elon isn't
quite convinced but what's the big deal
with fake accounts anyway sure there is
like nuisance and it's a shame that
people fall for these scams but it's not
worth holding enter acquisition over
right well Elon thinks it is for a few
reasons starting with the company's
business model Twitter makes money by
selling ad slots on their platform just
like most other social media platforms
but if 10 or 20 of Twitter accounts are
just Bots advertisers will be wasting a
significant number of Impressions on
useless accounts this would in turn lead
to lower conversion rates which relate
to less advertisers wanted to Market on
Twitter and eventually less revenue for
Twitter aside from Less ad Revenue Bots
also ruined Twitter's credibility Elon
wants to make Twitter into the Super
righteous place where free speech is
supported and the people can engage in
intellectual discussions about social
issues but people won't exactly be
enthused to do this if a bunch of the
platform is just bots so for Elon
dealing with the fake accounts is a
matter of protecting tourist credibility
amongst advertisers and users and
consequently he's taking it pretty
seriously Elon has requested a detailed
report that goes through how Twitter is
determining how many Bots there are but
Twitter has been reluctant to hand over
these details the most likely reason for
this is that they simply don't have the
details or they're not confident about
the details that they do have Twitter
CEO Prague was actually pretty upfront
about this he says that it's extremely
challenging to differentiate between
legit accounts with seemingly suspicious
activity and spam accounts with
seemingly legitimate activity so more
likely than not Twitter has been
scrambling to find more evidence to
support their claims before they hand
over a more detailed report to Elon
honestly I don't think Elon would cancel
the deal over Bots but if there are more
Bots than Twitter initially claimed Elon
may try to use this as a negotiating
point to drive down the acquisition
price
foreign
has secured most of the funding required
by Twitter he doesn't quite have all of
it at the time of making this video Elon
has committed to paying 33.5 billion
dollars in cash and he has secured 7.1
billion dollars worth of equity-based
financing but this only adds up to 40.6
billion dollars meaning that he stole
3.4 billion short from the 44 billion
dollar acquisition price Elon has
vaguely stated that the remaining amount
will also come from various loans but
the specifics have yet to be finalized
at one point he was in talks with a
group of private Equity firms to raise
two to three billion dollars but this
wasn't the makeup for the disparity this
was to reduce the amount of cash Elon
would have to put up maybe elon's goal
is to shaved on the acquisition price by
10 and to pay no more than 40 billion
for Twitter aside from not securing the
final amount Elon has become much more
cautious when it comes to equity-based
financing in may he was working on
getting a 12.5 billion margin loan based
on his Tesla stock but he has since
grabbed the idea this is likely due to
the stock market and Tesla stock getting
crushed since he made the deal with the
Twitter year since April Tesla stock has
sold off 45 percent to make things worse
it seems like Elon is forecasting isn't
potentially painful quarters to come for
Tesla recently he announced plans for
laying off 10 of their salary Workforce
he's also been talking about how to get
taxes and Giga Berlin are currently
gigantic money furnaces because they
can't get enough parts to ramp up
production Elon has even started
mentioning worries regarding bankruptcy
now I don't think Tesla isn't any risk
of going bankrupt in the imminent future
but based on everything Elon has been
saying it it looks like Tesla is likely
in for some painful quarters which could
drive the stock price even lower and the
last thing Elon would want is to get
margin called it at the bottom so it's
not surprising that he's being a lot
more cautious when it comes to
equity-based financing elon's not the
only one with second thoughts either the
banks are fearful that credit investors
won't buy the dead as long as Elon is
fighting Twitter regarding fake accounts
so they're waiting for the uncertainty
to subside it before they actually put
together the funds they're technically
not allowed to do this because the deal
is technically still on and Twitter can
actually take the banks to court for not
meeting their funding obligations but
the general consensus is that it's very
unlikely that Twitter would actually
waste money on taking these guys to
court after all if Elon calls off the
deal and it's not like the funding would
be that useful anyway so Twitter's best
bet is to just convince Elon that the
fake accounts are negligible issue or to
Simply settle for a lower purchase price
thank you
the points that we've discussed so far
are completely under elon's control at
any point he could just decide to
proceed it despite the fake accounts and
to ask for their financing he could just
sell off some more Tesla stock if he
really wanted to but even if Elon was
willing to do this it's not like he
could complete the deal right now anyway
because there are excellent factors that
are out of his control first of all we
have the HSR act or the hard Scott
rodino act like with any piece of
legislation the HSR act has a bunch of
stipulations and conditions but the part
that applies to the Twitter deal is the
30-day waiting period whenever a merger
or acquisition of a certain magnitude is
proposed the deal has to be reviewed by
the Federal Trade Commission and the U.S
Department of Justice these institutions
then have 30 days to review the deal and
either do nothing which is basically
equivalent to approving it or they can
request for more information just
because they request more information
and it does not mean that a deal is dead
per se but this would likely delay the
deal by months if not years usually
they're just looking to stop monopolies
from forming for example they wouldn't
want shell and Exxon to join or Boeing
an Airbus to join within the social
media scene they might not want Facebook
and Twitter to join but Elon does not
own any other social media companies
Tesla is a car company and SpaceX is a
rocket company so there's really no risk
of forming some sort of social media
Monopoly something that may concern them
is how much power this deal would give
Elon but I don't think that this would
be a game changer either I mean just
take a look at how much power Mark
Zuckerberg has even including the Bots
Twitter only has 330 million monthly
active users which is an insane amount
but only a fraction of Facebook WhatsApp
alone has over 2 billion monthly active
users and Instagram has another two
billion monthly active users given that
the government has yet to break up
Facebook I don't think they would put up
much resistance for the Twitter deal not
to mention that the 30 days have already
passed so it looks like a deal is good
to go from a regulation standpoint Elon
and Twitter do still need a few more
government approvals but this was really
the main hurdle regulation wise even
after after all of this though there is
still one more hurdle that the Twitter
deal has to jump over and that's
shareholder approval Twitter is a public
company so public shareholders do have a
say in what happens to the company
Twitter hasn't yet revealed what date
the voting will take place but it's
expected to happen in Late July or early
August many shareholders do have
concerns regarding Elon taking over the
company but the general consensus is
that the shareholders will approve the
deal and once they do it it's just a
matter of actually completing the deal
thank you
something that we haven't yet discussed
is what happens if Elon backs away from
the deal and the reason for this is that
he can't really back away first of all
Elon will have to pay a one billion
breakup fee but that's the least of his
concerns unless it's revealed that
Twitter is upon this game or something
Twitter will have rights to sue Elon for
breaching contract and they could easily
launch a multi-billion dollar lawsuit
against them Not only would this be a
massive [ __ ] but it would be a
permanent stain on his reputation and
let's be real here do you really think
that he bought nine percent of Twitter
sold at 8.5 billion dollars worth of
Tesla stock secured a bunch of funding
and it made a 44 billion offer just to
walk away due to bots that he was
already aware of that makes no sense
whatsoever these are all moves of a
serious buyer and the bot thing is
really just a negotiation tactic it may
actually help him shave off a few
billion from the acquisition price but
we'll just have to wait and see in the
meantime he's looking to minimize his
margin risk and ensure that the Twitter
deal won't go over his Tesla stick and
given that the sharehold the boat
doesn't have to take place till October
24th Elon and Twitter have plenty of
time to figure this out and its chances
are I think they will figure it out and
that the deal will take place probably
by the end of this year but that's just
what I think do you think the Twitter
deal will go through comment that down
below also drop a like if you hope that
Twitter becomes less toxic whether Elon
takes over or not and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community to
suggest future video ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one